all right speed run
one game
15 plus 10
and then we call it let's go
[Music]
michael angelo from greece
okay one e3 that's the van crews opening
um you can play either e5 or d5 i like
d5
just because if you play e5
if you play e5 y can play d4 and
transpose to a tempo up front french so
my preferred move is d5
okay so d3 is kind of like the hippo
and obviously here we should control the
center with e5
my guess is that he's going to be
playing the
okay no or is he going to push like
all of his pawns up one square
well let's see i mean our our approacher
is just to develop pieces
our approach is is just to develop
pieces and see what white does
um
how do we develop pieces well there's
multiple approaches uh to handling these
kinds of troll openings
a lot of people get way too caught up in
trying to figure out where the pieces
belong really anything is good you can
play c5 if you want or you can play the
c6 you can play knight c6 i like
starting with knight f6
uh just to preserve the possibility of
pushing the c pawn up to c5 h3
now in terms of the dark squared bishop
where should we put it what do you guys
think should we put it on c5 d6 or e7
and in this case there is at one square
which is better than the others in this
case
yeah for sure bishop d6 uh
better than bishop b7 because
bishop d6 at least reinforces the pawn
on e5
yeah generally the bishop belongs on d6
and you've often seen me play the move
pawn c6 in conjunction with bishop d6 i
really like that setup
but it's too early to decide what we're
doing with the c pawn because we still
have
certain developing moves that we know we
have to make and one of them is of
course the castle so let's castle
knight d2
and by the way those disappointed that
we're not having a mainstream opening i
really do think that a lot of people
need practice
playing against these kinds of offbeat
openings so it's not a waste of time
um i think we can extract constructive
value from this and i'm glad that our
opponent isn't doing something too
trolly
okay knight d2 once again it's really a
matter of taste how how we want to
handle
this position some people like to have a
bigger center and go c5
totally fine
some people uh like me i like to move c6
in such positions just building up a
nice little center or you can just play
it conventionally with knight c6
uh let's play i really like to play c6
in these types of positions just to
reinforce the pawn and in case white
fianchetto is the bishop which is often
going to be the case oh and there we go
white's played e4 and aren't we happy
that we played c6 in order to
support the pawn on d now we don't have
to worry about e takes d5 and we can
focus on developing the rest of our
pieces now i should point out that the
way white is playing it's not terrible
it's not like we're that much better
we have kind of like a reverse philidor
up maybe two or three tempi so black is
better but
you shouldn't expect to win the game in
five moves against an open even against
an opening like this because
our opponent hasn't done anything
that
you know that much in violation of
principles he's developed his knight
he's controlled part of the center and
so
uh we shouldn't go crazy here so what
should black do how should black
continue developing
a lot of people here would go bishop e6
that's not my preferred move
i feel like our bishop should remain on
c8 for the time being
um as i've said
on several occasions development isn't
always a race it isn't always about just
bringing all of your pieces out
automatically
uh let's play knight bd7
and i think the common idea that we will
apply in this position is to reroute
this knight to what square re-route this
knight to g6 kind of rue lopez style
we're going to do that by playing rookie
8 knight f8 knight g6 my coach would
always say that a piece can be developed
even sitting on its initial square
you might say well what does that mean
well what that means is let's imagine a
scenario right where white finishes
developing in castles
that bishop on segate could sacrifice
itself on h3 without having made a
single prior move now would we say that
the bishop on c8 was not developed well
not really develop developing a piece
isn't always strictly necessary
and
the bishop isn't doing much on e6
uh in comparison to c8 so we're leaving
it on c8 for now
and we can play a5 here and expand a
little bit on the queen side i honestly
don't see why not a5 stops before
so let's uh let's do some queen side
expansion we're not in a big hurry to
play rookie aiden knight of f8 and now
we can play rookie in knight fa now that
we've grabbed some space and prevented
b4
shouldn't we try to open up the center
soon yeah well ideally we would but
unfortunately we can't um if we had a
way to open up the center we would
d d take c4 doesn't really open up the
center in fact it helps white by opening
up the diagonal for the bishop
so in this case yeah we we should just
keep the central tension if that makes
sense all right let's go rookie eight
which is a good move in and of itself it
just gets the rook into the center
knight e2
okay
now we have two different pathways
we have two different possible pathways
we can go knight f8 knight g6 as
previously planned
what's the other path that the knight
could take in order to land on a similar
square
where else could we go with this knight
potentially
and
we have a a
we basically have two plans here we can
kind of play on the king side we can
yeah knight c5 is the other idea and
that hits white where it hurts that d3
pawn is a major weakness right
so can you propose a plan and see this
is why we didn't develop the bishop on
c8 until now
can you propose a plan
uh that involves getting our pieces onto
squares such that we apply pressure on
the d3 pawn what little maneuver can we
play yeah i call this the hyper
fianchetto we can play b6
and follow it up with bishop a6 an
underrated maneuver so that would be
one option
let's follow through on our initial plan
though and let's keep b6 bishop a6 in
mind as a potential follow-up
possibility but first
let's take care of this knight
okay knight g3 perfect that plays right
into our hands i was a little bit
worried that
our opponent would go g3
because then the knight on g6 would be a
little bit lame and in that case we
would have gone knight e6
now
this knight can obviously jump all the
way to f4 and so knight g6
makes perfect sense if
they go knight f5 then
we play bishop takes f5 and
force the pawn to recapture that's not
dangerous what should we do now
should we play b6 or do we have or do we
have a better move
yeah definitely knight f4 definitely
knight f4 because we now attack the pawn
on g2 and if he castles king side then a
sacrifice on h3 becomes a definite
possibility
in addition we could eliminate that
bishop
okay bishop f3
now
in playing bishop f3 immediately
we realize that the pawn on d3 is left
further weakened
so
now
now that the pawn is only protected by
the queen it makes perfect sense to play
b6 and bishop a6
we end up combining our two ideas which
always which is always fun
the hyper fiance
we also could contemplate throwing in g6
at some point in order to fully limit
the mobility of the knight on f on on g3
because remember once you play bishop a6
we are we will no longer be protecting
the f5 square and so knight f5 will
become a possibility nothing terrible
about it we could just drop our bishop
back to f8
uh but something we could consider
restricting even further
and okay knight f5 is played and this is
to my eyes a decisive mistake
and what we're about to do is is going
to be pretty instructive
what we're about to do is going to be
pretty instructive so what should we do
what what should we start with
actually let me think for a second there
and there and there
yeah we should take that night
we should eliminate that night that
forces the pawn from e4 to move to f5
where it's serious weakness
and we have a very very powerful
follow-up to this move though partially
the reason that i'm taking on f5
consists in the follow-up
now
anytime a pawn moves away from the
center you have to assess how that
changes
the dynamic of the center what now
becomes possible
in addition you have to factor in the
fact that the king is uncastled a lot of
you guys are correctly looking at the
movie for
that move has to be calculated
so e4 pawn takes e4
okay
pawn takes e4
and then white can try knight takes c4
and we have to find something against
that move
and there is one just give me a second
there's
actually a lot of stuff to calculate
there and i will show you
some of this after the game
but there's
believe it or not
e4 i think is not quite as clear-cut as
it may seem to be
so takes takes knight takes knight takes
bishop takes and i know a lot of you are
thinking that queen e7 in that position
wins the bishop but it doesn't
can you tell me why not
after everything is captured on e4 takes
takes takes takes takes
what happens after queen e7
yeah white has f3 defending the bishop
now you might say but doesn't f3 weaken
the king and it does and we can give a
check on h4 in that position but the
king drops to f1 i'm not entirely
convinced that that's
winning i think black is doing great
what do you do in such a scenario well
you need to take a couple of moments and
see if you can't find anything better on
the initial move a lot of problems are
solved
by just thinking differently about the
position
now let me
float an interesting idea to you guys
what if we forgot for a second about e4
what if there's a different approach
what if we can attack a different
weakness
and i claim that if you think of it that
way
you can play a move here and maybe the
computer will make you for work but
there is a very simple move that causes
unsolvable problems for white
what are white's other weaknesses the
pawn in f5 is itself a weakness right
it's undefended
yeah a lot of you guys are thinking also
about knight takes d3 and e4 another
very interesting possibility
but i want to play it even simpler than
that
yeah queen d7
let's just go queen d7 i know it's very
anticlimactic but it's very effective
because this pawn can barely be defended
and if white goes g4
with that incredible further weakening i
can guarantee you that e4 is going to be
so much more effective he castles we
pick up the pawn and not only do we pick
up that pawn we are going to likely pick
up another one on d3 that pawn simply
cannot be defended
and that doesn't mean we're not going to
play e4 where we might play that in the
future just because he's castle doesn't
mean the king is going to be safe look
at our bishop on d6 once we play e4 that
bishop is going to open up you can start
thinking about putting together
batteries
and mating ideas in conjunction with the
knight
and this is the point that i've been
making all speed run long that's
actually the operating motivation behind
this third speed run is
this kind of simple chess is highly
underrated and you have to know how to
play it
in order to
get to the next level and really develop
the style that you want to play in
is it possible to sack the knight on h3
absolutely that that is a candidate move
in some positions
but again we might not need that not
need to do that we might just be able to
take on d3
was queen c8 any better for queen a6
so i'll talk about that after the game
but unnecessary what is the point of
getting the queen to a6 it is to attack
the d3 pawn right well you're doing that
anyway from f5 it's just that you've
also captured a pawn and you're also
aiming at the king side so
the point of the hyper fiance is no
longer necessary
but yeah e4 led to complications and
i'll be honest initially i did think
that we would play e4 but as i started
to calculate i realized that there were
some
um
some complications we'll check with an
engine afterward and i'll show you guys
what it is that i what deterred me
ultimately from playing e4
okay so now the first big think by our
opponent
in the meantime we can start pondering
the question of what we want to take on
d3 with both pieces are fine
but okay queen d1
answers that question for us i like to
talk about the queen as kind of the
supporting actress sometimes getting the
queen right into the thick of things
is actually counterproductive and you
want the queen sort of back in the
shadows
operating as more of the war general
um so from that perspective knight takes
d3 is what appeals to me intuitively
intuitively i i want to take on d3 with
the knight yasser is the originator of
that idea
but in this
specific instance queen takes d3 is also
completely overwhelming because the
queen is unassailable it cannot be
attacked bishop e2 is impossible what is
the queen doing on d3 well it's also
attacking the pawn on c3
now this is a case of two incredibly
good options i really think it doesn't
matter i think both moves
are completely overwhelming
um
let's stick with the queen
let's take let's violate the rule and
take with the queen this time
the reason why is because i think
i have a feeling that he's going to go
bishop b2 and then we're going to win a
piece
or at least we're gonna win more
material
yeah very good egolian e4 follow-up
traps the bishop because the e2 square
is protected by two of our pieces
and in response to bishop g4 we can do
the classic h5 bishop f5 g6 and the
bishop is going to be trapped
we're spoiled for choice important not
to waste too much time in these
situations knight p1 is the best move
see this is why i wanted to take with a
knight
problem is this might force some sort of
an end game
and i'm not feeling
i'm not in an endgame mood right now
okay so because i'm not in an endgame
mood what can we do
absolutely no need for knight takes h3
guys g takes h3
and i don't see the attack if we give a
check on g6 remember with this bishop on
f3
white can drop that bishop back to g2
and that bishop acts as a very annoying
defender queen g6 mistake
the the move here is queen f5 who can
explain to me why what is the difference
between queen and g6 and queen if i'm
not a big mistake but nonetheless a
mistake what does queen g6 allow
think concretely
what does it allow it allows white to
take on f4 why is that bad it's not bad
because it's a trade queen f5 also
allows that move it's bad because we
have to take on f4 with the pawn and if
you think about it that bishop on d6 is
going to be
uh not fulfilling its full potential
that pawn on f4 is gonna be a very hard
pawn uh to move out of the way it's
blockaded by the bishop does that make
sense
so let's move the queen back to f5 in a
classical game i would contemplate
the movie four here because i normally
would not mind an end game up two pawns
we're completely winning in that end
game
for the purposes of this game and of
course now we take with the queen
we're going to try to keep queens on the
board and we're threatening the move e4
now
probably g3 is is going to be our
opponent's choice
definitely
i think i should have taken on d3 with a
knight but it's fine
yeah the move queen d2 here is a little
annoying
i i that question is so i'm getting a
question about like what is the rule of
thumb for trading
queens versus keeping queens on the
board
i mean i've been talking about this for
most of the speed run right there is no
algorithm you just have to rule on a
case-by-case basis okay c4
allowing e4 now it's all over mate
and if g3 then we take the bishop
because the pawn will no longer defend
that bishop
and in general there's no algorithm for
anything
any kind of
general decision
there are rules of thumb there's
stuff that can help you make the right
decision but
everything in chess has to be done on a
case-by-case basis at the end of the day
okay so he allows us to to jackman
nice
nice game
and really the most interesting moment
in this game was
was that that moment when we could play
e4
then corey's opening e3
uh yeah e5 d4 is a little bit boring
because a lot of the time you kind of
end up taking on d4 and then it's a
exchange french with colors reverse it's
totally equal
probably knight c6 is the most
principled move here but then i can go
knight f3
so ultimately this is a reversed french
with a tempo down for black nothing too
impressive i like d5 if you're a king's
indian player by the way
uh the other way you can meet e3 is by
playing knight f6 and g6 you can play
king's indian setup against it basically
whatever opening you play against one d4
you can play that setup against e3 and
against b3 as well by the way
okay so d5 thank you thirsty
for the 15 months of course
so d3e5 yeah so c3 here i thought he was
gonna troll us but he ended up playing
reasonably normal queen c2 knight d2
and e4 obviously many many tempe have
has been lost
uh with white
okay knight bd7
so everything here i explained a5 how
does this stop b4 the reason this stops
before is because you take
then the rook is undefended you have to
notice this x-ray and you just play
bishop takes before
so a5 is almost always a good move to
throw in in such positions it restricts
the mobility of the queen side pawns
okay rookie a knight f8 knight g6 yeah
so i think white should have played g3
here
i think white should have played g3 and
fiance
here we would have gotten the knight to
e6
g perez says i don't get how g3 was bad
for black tonight well think of it this
way robert loves to point this out
anytime
there are two squares between a pawn and
the knight that are on the same file
it's generally going to be bad for the
knight why is that because the pawn
dominates the knight the pawn controls
both of the knights advancing squares
the knight
can really do nothing except retreat
that was retreating inherently bad no
but the knight doesn't have any more
appealing to retreat to
now this situation isn't always bad
sometimes in a different set of
circumstances you can simply sacrifice a
knight on f4 i'm sure you guys have seen
examples of that you can go like this
but this obviously is premature in this
case this is only only possible in
situations where
you know white's king is castled and
you're ready to attack
normally
uh normally this situation is
to be avoided and can result in mass
restriction of your pieces
in general just this idea of restricting
pieces is very important identifying
your opponent's pieces that are
potentially active and then restricting
them with your pawns
and by the way i want to make two other
points and both of them i'm going to
make through the lens of
illustrative games one of them by
wilhelm stein it's one of them by me
since we're on this topic i know we're
going in a bit of a detour but this is
important peace restriction let's have a
look at
a steinis gamer he does something very
very similar just to hammer in this
concept
first game is this english against
steinitz from 1883 english was a strong
player
we join in this position black is
obviously better if you look at black's
pieces works on a good square two
bishops
um and english plays the move knight b3
and in this position steinis makes a
very instructive sequence of moves what
do you think he plays take your time
what does black do in this position
and this is exactly on the theme of what
we just discussed
excellent so steinis plays b6 first he
restricts the knight first he restricts
the knight
h3 bishop b6 or captain how does he
follow up
and this next move is equally
instructive very good and you guys are
already getting it even before he got to
the moment he plays c5
if you look at how this pawn chain
impacts white's pieces it doesn't allow
bishop d4 that's that's the point and
this knight is look at how this knight
is dominated all of its squares
are taken away by the pawns
and steinins ends up winning a very very
nice game he just squeezes white off the
board just keeps pushing his pawns
and keeps pushing and then this idea a5
a4
getting that knight out of b3 this is
going to dovetail
on to the next game bishop c4
complete domination
trading off white's only act of peace
i.e the bishop leaving white with the
lame knight
and then trading the rooks and at the
end literally white is just left with
this totally restricted knight it's
restricted by the bishop
92 and steinis is correctly calculated
the pawn end game is winning because the
king shoulders white's king and then
comes around and takes the pawn
how do you know you're not overextending
well
what does it mean to overextend
overextend means you have too many
things to defend and if you actually
look at black's pawns they're all
defending each other
black spawns are all defending each
other other than the a7 pawn which is
unattackable so you're not overextending
as long as you're making sure that
everything is reasonably protected
and it's an end game right it's harder
to overextend yourself in an end game
but now let's say have a look at one of
my games
really to hammer home
this notion of using your pawns to
restrict your opponent's pieces
black to play
what did i come up with here and the
first move i think most of you should
see almost immediately but perhaps the
follow-up idea will be less obvious
so again we have a knight on g3
the knight wants to go to f5 and force
me to give up one of my bishops so we
start with g6 now you might say well how
do i know that i can get away with this
move isn't it weakening well it is
but white's pieces are too clearly too
passive to really take and take
advantage of that but what did i do
after white castle what is the follow-up
to g6
bingo h5
okay he goes b4
h4 and forcing the knight all the way
back
and he ended up just giving away this
pawn
but this makes a tremendous impact on
the coordination white's pieces so these
ideas are important using your pawns to
restrict pieces using your pawns to
chase pieces away
okay back to the game
hopefully that made sense and helps you
understand that a little bit more so to
summarize after g3 it is better not to
go to g6 it's probably better to go to
c5 and resort to the second plan of
attacking the d3 pawn
okay
knight g3
um
this of course this is a bad move this
is a bad move because it gives us a
direct pathway to f4
um
knight g6
yeah stein it's english is the game i
really think of as a symbol for
restricting your opponent's pieces
bishop e2 knight f4 and already white is
in trouble
bishop f3 now this weakens the d3 pawn
and we play b6
and knight f5 is the decisive mistake
and
white should have castled here
and how should white meet the move ace
bishop a6 what should white do here does
isn't white losing
not d4 that gives up the exchange white
has to play c4
and for extra credit what should black
do in this position i think probably
taking on c4 is it's good to throw this
in
but in this position what should black
do in order to figure that out you again
have to use the drawback principle okay
you know our plan has been successful we
have forced white to play c4 and what
effect does that have on the position
well it weakens the d4 square that is
the main thing you should notice
um some of you are suggesting b5 i don't
like this move it doesn't really do
anything it doesn't create a threat it
looks good but white can simply keep
developing
instead i really like the idea of going
bishop c5 and aiming for d4
the secondary idea that i like is knight
back to e6 and then going to d4 with the
knight
very good uh saved by got2 deserve a sub
for that but i probably would go bishop
c5 and then bishop d4 and look at how
many squares we're controlling the
knight is good the bishop is good we've
got an outpost and we would potentially
proceed to cement that bishop by playing
c5
now you might say well what about this
bishop isn't this bishop bad now yeah it
is and after we play c5 we can drop it
back to b7 so that it pressures e4
again sometimes your pieces do a job on
a square and then their services are
required elsewhere that's okay
you don't have to just rush to play b5
here and activate this bishop it's done
its job
okay so
not every piece needs to distribute the
covert vaccine
bishop takes f5 he takes f5 now we get
to the fun part why did i not play e4
so
let's start with the simple line dd4
d4984
knight e4 bishop b4 queen e7 f3
in this position i was simply not
convinced that black is
black is uh
anything other black is full
compensation fact no i think black is
doing great so queen h4 check there's an
idea i just spotted which i didn't see
during the game
now if queen f2 because of the pin we
have obviously a fork
if the king goes to the d-file then it
goes from the frying pan to the fire and
this just looks unthinkable there's a
beautiful move after king f1 there is
such a sexy move here
not queen g3 but you're on the right
track think about this square what do
you want to be on g3 what do you want to
put on g3
is it the queen
really riley
not rook takes c4 that doesn't do
anything like just recaptures knight h5
and white simply cannot stop this deadly
move knight g3 is gonna come with such
massive effect
even though white can technically defend
against the fork oh but now bishop c5
check and it's simply mate
after king h2 the queen comes to g3 no
this is game over
this is simply game over knight comes to
g3 and it's and it's and it's crushing
okay so i missed this
and uh
this just shows you that you can't stop
calculating i kind of ended at this
moment and i said it's not that clear
and i don't really blame myself for that
knight h5 is not so easy to spot from a
distance
how dare i miss this that's right so i
guess this was good
oh but wait
no i think i found an improvement for
white i think i found an improvement for
white
rather than playing f3 what else can
white do here
i just spotted something in this
position
no not bishop e3 the bishop is hanging
the bishop is hanging on e4 bishop takes
f4
if bishop takes f4 then white plays f3
and there's no longer a knight
this is still very strong for black but
i think this is quite a bit more
defensible
and if queen takes e4 which looks like
it wins a piece
looks like it wins a piece it's a fork
but again bishop drops back to e3
so
i guess i'm vindicated in the end yeah
there was this move now the second thing
we have to look at
is queen e7 in this position
and this just shows you that you
shouldn't automatically grab pieces you
have to consider yeah queen e7 instead
of knight takes e4
but here i found a crazy idea i thought
that white could castle
knight takes c4 and then rookie one and
i couldn't find a way for us to keep
this extra knight
we'll check the engine move at the end
i just couldn't find a way to secure
this knight on e4 and i thought white
wins it back and the position is quite
unclear
so
ultimately this is the reason i didn't
play four i thought it was too messy
now there was a really interesting
possibility of taking on d3 first and
then playing for this i think is
extremely strong
but also not as convincing as i would
have liked it to be what should white do
in this position who can tell me how
should white deal with this
in fact every move loses except this one
and that i can tell you for sure
because if the queen moves away then we
take the bishop with the discovered
check and white's position falls apart
so white has to give up a piece in the
right way
yeah bishop takes c4 is correct
and the point is that after knight takes
before white kind of escapes with a
castle
and if we take with the pawn i thought
that white can drop the queen back
and
white is holding on although after even
probably the move e3 black's attack is
incredibly strong
yeah you could check with the knight but
then the king just drops to f1 why take
with the bishop and not with a knight
asks vince flee because if you take with
a knight you take with a pawn and you
haven't dealt with a fork you've just
uh you know thrown oil onto the fire you
still lose the bishop
okay
so with that in mind we decided on a
much simpler approach
and we just end up taking all of his
pawns now fighted gun g3
then knight takes d3 is tremendously
strong because the queen has this extra
pressure on the f5 pawn
okay g i perez is asking
in this line
so i'm not sure where you're talking
about like where do you mean the knight
some people were saying knight takes g2
check that's a possibility but the king
just drops to f1
yeah so anyways um back to the game
queen d7 castles queen takes f5 maybe
white could have been more resilient but
ultimately the game is already over here
what about bishop g4
on bishop g4 we can just play h5 and dis
pry that bishop away from
that square
i don't think quite as a defense here i
mean maybe pawn g4 was the best
but
now e4 is crushing because in addition
to everything else
by playing queen d7 you have to sort of
catalog the changes that happened one of
the things that happens is that the
rooks become connected well how does
that help well now we have a whole set
of tactics that involve sacrificing one
rook and bringing the other one
to its aid so rook takes c4 is the win
and then rookie 8.
so this one move really changes
everything
and after castle's queen f5 okay we win
two puns the rest doesn't really require
analysis again light could have defended
somewhat more resiliently but this is
just
you know this is just sad
now let's check with the
engine um my guess is that
you know queen d7 might even be the best
move i mean
i don't know
we'll see
it's saying that oh it's saying it
actually likes knight c5 if you're
interesting
oh knight g3 is best wow
i wouldn't necessarily trust that it's
on depth 15 though
that's a very low depth i would let it
reach f25 but anyways let's get to the
moment we want to see
27 is good you can see that it's
basically keeps the evaluation it was
saying knight takes d3 is best so e4
um is not convincing it it goes all the
way down to minus two
so i was right e4 is a mistake
and if queen e7
yeah then white is better
castle's 94
um and now and now either bishop takes
f4 first or rookie one immediately
and uh
black loses the advantage so
that d4 is not good here because white
can just push the pawn so knight d3
queen d3 e4
bishop before de queen e2
yeah and now e3 is very important
sacking the pawn
opening up the e file and then slamming
in knight d5 and white's position falls
apart at the seams
so yeah there are two approaches to this
position but queen d7 as you can see
keeps an overwhelming evaluation
then queen takes f5
yeah queen g6 was best wow so it wasn't
even
first queen gci and then knight takes c3
okay that's just computer stuff
queen f5 is best actually keeping the
queens is the fastest
yeah
so you can see simple chess
often produces the desired effect
in a better way than than convoluted
chess and we never needed to stock on h3
or even to think about that
okay that was a great game short but i
think there was a lot of instructive
value in it i hope you enjoyed
see you guys later
[Music]
you